you have said talked a lot about
security guarantees and now we've seen
your proposals you also say you have no
intention of invading ukraine so will
you guarantee unconditionally that you
will not invade ukraine or any other
sovereign country or does that depend on
how negotiations go
and another question what is it do you
think that the west does not understand
about russia or about your intentions
thank you
speaking of the security guarantees and
what it will depend upon or if something
will depend upon the negotiations our
actions will not depend on the
negotiation they will depend on the
unconditional compliance with the
russian security demands today and in
the historical context in this sense we
have made it clear that any further nato
movement to the east is unacceptable
there is nothing unclear about this we
are not deploying our missiles over at
the borders of the us no on the other
hand the us is deploying its missiles
close to our home on there on the porch
of our house
so
are we
demanding something excessive we're
simply asking them not to deploy their
attack systems over at our home
what is so unusual or peculiar about
that
so what would the americans think if we
for example
decided to
come to the border between say canada
and the united states
or
mexico
and simply deploy our missiles over
there well
does
did mexico and the us never have any
territorial disputes what about
california what about texas
did you forget about that but everything
seems to have come down nobody remembers
those things just like the way they
remember about crimea we try not to
remember
the situation in ukraine who created
that who started the crisis
was that lenin
when he declared the soviet union in
1922 and then the constitution of 1924
following his death
was following the principles of lenin
this is a matter of security not just
history this is about security it is not
the negotiations that matter it is the
outcome the result i've reiterated this
many times and you're well aware that
we said not an inch to the east
that was the nato guaranteed in 1990
so what became of that
they fooled us
we've seen five waves of nato expansion
now they're in romania and in poland
and they're deploying the relevant
attack systems over there that's what
we're talking about you should finally
understand we're not threatening anyone
we did not come to the u.s borders or to
the uk about us
no they they came to our borders and now
they're saying that ukraine will also
join nato and they will deploy their
systems there or not just nato they will
simply deploy it on a bilateral basis
they will deploy their military bases
and their tax systems that's what we're
talking about and you keep demanding
some guarantees from us you must give us
the guarantees it is up to you and you
must do this immediately right now
instead of keep talking about this for
decades
and they use this small talk and
soft talk about the need for guarantees
of security for everyone this is exactly
what we mean we are not threatening
anybody
and now to the second part of your
question could you repeat that please
what is it that you think that the west
does not understand about russia or
about your intentions no
yes exactly
well you know
what we understand what you understand
or what you don't understand sometimes
it seems to me that we live in two
different worlds i was speaking about
very obvious things how can you not
understand that
you say you will not expand and then you
keep expanding
you say we will have equal guarantees
for everyone on the number of
international agreements
and then we see there is no equality or
no equal security
see here's the thing
back in
1918
one of the assistance of woodrow wilson
the u.s president said
that
the whole world would feel calmer and
safer if
today's enormous russia
would be replaced
with the states of siberia and four more
states
in the european part of russia
that was set in
1918 and in 1991 we separated into 12
separate parts
it seems to me that our partners were
not satisfied with that they think that
russia is that too large even the
european countries have turned
themselves into a
union of
states they are quite small states with
populations of 60 to 80 million people
but even after the dissolution of the
soviet union we only had
146 million people and that is too much
for the west i think that is the only
explanation for their constant pressure
against us back in the 1990s
the soviet union did everything it could
to build normal relations with the west
with the united states i will keep
saying this and i will repeat for your
viewers and listeners
out there from the media that you
represent i didn't quite get that but
that doesn't matter
our nuclear sites
our military nuclear sites
had experts from the u.s intelligence
authorities they were going there that
was their job to visit the russian
military nuclear sites they spent their
whole days over there and the russian
government had advices from
the cia working inside of it what else
did you need
why did you have to support the
terrorists in northern caucasus
and use
that terrorist organizations for to
reach your goals and break down the
russian federation this was exactly what
you were doing and as a former director
of the fsb i know that
we were working with the double agents
and they were reporting to us on the
tasks of the western intelligence
agencies why did you have to do that
you should have done something different
perhaps treat russia as a possible ally
and strengthen trust but no instead you
tried to keep breaking us up and then
you started the nato expansion to the
east we were saying don't do that you
had promised you wouldn't and they say
where is it put in written form nowhere
well then naf off and we
don't care about your concerns
and every time we
kept
responding and trying to make obstacles
we were expressing our concerns about
that but they say no
you
can do whatever you want about your
concerns we will do whatever we need one
two three four five
we witnessed five waves of nato
expansion
why can't they understand what is
unclear i believe everything is clear we
are thinking about our own security